good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday hope everyone
had a fabulous fabulous fabulous
fabulous weekend
I think a lot of people had a fabulous
weekend I think we all had a fabulous
weekend because it was a hurla day
weekend not for everyone by the way what
I learned yesterday is that like nobody
respects indigenous people's day and I
think that's disgusting yeah not for
everyone though it was for us we wound
up working yesterday anyway because we
dropped a hysterical patreon episode
that everyone should listen to We like
recapped our weekends we helped me study
for the permit test we recapped House of
dragons Jacks the thing about us is that
we you can't put us in a box you know
you can't put us in a box so tell us
you're gonna record an hour talking
about Jackie taking her driver's test
like we're gonna talk about Damon we're
gonna talk about raniera yeah we just
had so much catching up to do so we did
all of that really in yesterday's
episode on patreon we're pretty much
caught up but I guess I'll just recap my
weekend again because I was in Atlanta
on Friday visiting our Georgia toasters
at Total Wine for a spritz meet and
greet which was so wonderful if any of
you who aren't patrons but we're at the
meet and greet um I was just raving
about the toasters that showed up and
showed out it totally was in Atlanta I
was also
um slamming the traffic that I
experienced in that town I don't know
how you guys do it and also all the
distracted driving that I did see on the
highway not gonna lie not to be a snitch
or anything but she did see not to be a
narc but everyone in Atlanta was
distracted driving I even saw someone
driving on the highway he opened up his
his door he was the driver he opened his
door to spit in the to hakalugi I've
seen people do that was he in motion or
he was in motion no that's psychotic
that is quite literally psychotic but
like that's how I feel about eating like
if if I'm eating while I'm driving like
everyone in the car is going down
yeah pretense what you're eating too
something so delicious yeah it's a salad
I'm not gonna feel like impassioned
enough to distract myself from the road
if it's a nugget honestly
watch out
watch out also speaking of delicious and
tasty food I made a chili on Saturday it
was a gloomy day here so I thought chili
and also I was looking at my time happen
a year ago that day I had made a chili
so I was just inspiring myself and
Olivia Shapiro and Kayla came over for
chilly night and they were so blown away
reviews by about your corn muffins from
scratch I made homemade corn muffins too
they were so good and I'm so excited for
you to come down and visit me because I
will be cooking you my chili and you
really kind of reignited the debate
Nationwide about uh corn muffins versus
cinnamon buns when it comes to chili
never heard about a cinnamon bun and
chili in my life and also then people
were saying they have peanut butter
sandwiches with their chili did you not
see all of the comments for peanut
butter sandwiches
yeah it's twisted world that we live in
I'm disgusted
I'm offended
and I'm downright
shook it's truly Twisted I I've never
had a cinnamon bun with chili that just
seems to me like two good things that
don't need to put together that one
could enjoy separately the thing is the
worst cinnamon bun in the world is
delicious like try making a bad cinnamon
bun I I'm still gonna eat the whole
thing Cinnabon
is it only a Cinnabon if it comes from
Cinnabon headquarters Cinnabon TM wow
that's a great name it's kind of like
Band-Aid
because it's a because like I'm gonna
call it a Cinnabon whether or not it
comes from Cinnabon you know if it's a
generic Band-Aid I'm still going to call
it a Band-Aid not an adhesive strip I
thought you were gonna say it's a great
name it's kind of like dish issues
dishes well of course one thing about me
is like if your brand is leaning heavily
into the concept of melding words
together like I'm gonna be a patron a
lifelong customer I will respect your
brand like honestly I did stop buying
Cascade dish pods when they had that
commercial about dish issues and didn't
call it dishes because to me that lacks
creativity that lacks Innovation it
lacks inspiration it lacks Ingenuity and
I don't personally like to align myself
with a brand that doesn't take word
melding seriously
100 or a brand that doesn't advertise on
this show there's no time for it that's
the other thing like if you're just
gonna be so dumb and ugly I can't relate
to you also speaking of brands that
advertise on the show I made my chili in
my Caraway pot stunning clean up what
clean up totally that Caraway pot in the
Shapiro's were quaking when they saw all
my cowboy I was like yeah they're a
sponsor or work because I made a chili
in like a a different Dutch oven the
other day and I had to boil a
dishwashing pot on the stove to get the
crust off the bottom this is not even an
ad for caraway they're not even a
sponsor today yeah no and
it changed the game for sure
it's really like a stunning weekend I
hope everyone is feeling good with where
they're at in their hearts in their
souls in their minds are you feeling
good with where you're at in your heart
and soul mine no no I'm not I was up all
[ __ ] night I could not sleep even
Josie B ASMR couldn't put me to sleep my
stupid ass husband is snoring so loud
just like rubbing it in like yeah [ __ ]
I'm asleep and you're not and it was
just like miserable and then I slept
past my alarm and I'm just like I'm just
having a morning you know ever I feel
like it's just that time of year it's
like winter now so it's like those
mornings are like we're not having good
mornings anymore we're like we're all
doing our routines and like being cute
and curling our hair like we're having
winter mornings winter mornings hit
different because it's dark out and it
reminds me of like getting ready for
school but you're so contradictory no no
offense I don't mean to comfort you
because like you love when I'm used to
it I'm used to it at this point I'm used
to you coming for me at this point it's
like I sit down in this chair and I'm
like what is Jackie gonna throw at me
today this is what I'm gonna throw at
you you love winter don't be too hurt by
that did I say for one minute that I did
not like winter
you don't like winter mornings that's a
big part of the day I actually never
even said I don't like winter mornings I
said they hit different once again not
listening again I am not being heard on
my own show
I'm reading between the lines you said
it in a negative way read between the
lines
wow mcclartia and I'm again I'm the one
attacking this is so you like attacking
me and then when I defend myself she's
like I'm being attacked you know what it
is it's victim mentality it's on you and
it's a you problem and I will not engage
in this in this tense discourse any
longer
and here I was about to compliment your
windbreaker well this windbreaker holds
a really special place to my heart
because I never would have bought it
because it was insanely expensive but
thankfully I was with a pusher who
pushes people all right Jacqueline we
were shopping at the stunning fabulous
Highland Park Village in Dallas a mere
few years ago and we got to the store
and honestly
I don't know if I've told you this I
think maybe I've said it on the podcast
how we got to that store and like the
like the snotty sales associate was like
so up your [ __ ] ass like I might as
well have been the [ __ ] on his shoe and
I'm like yes I would like some fabulous
things as well but I was like big and
fat and in luxury stores like oh you're
fat you're basically you're done you're
done so like he was like putting this
first stole on you getting you bags from
the back and I was like hi yes I have a
lot of money and I'd like to spend it
here and he couldn't be bothered with my
big fat ass and then I bought this
windbreaker and like I was like I'm
gonna I'm gonna show him the fat girl
can buy too and he literally didn't even
look at me didn't even care but was
happy to take the commission
and you know what at the end of the day
you're the big winner because the big
winner
the windbreaker looks so great on you
you've gotten so much wear out of it
it's a perfect transitional item for any
season and I feel so good about my
pushing Endeavors if you're watching
listening as a podcast it's a Fendi
windbreaker which is like such an insane
thing to do I do feel like I got a good
price given inflation like now if I said
how much it was it'd be like that's it
and every time I wear it I feel like I
slash the price in half so like let's
let's be transparent with our audience
this jacket was 1500 which is psychotic
like I understand now I've worn it about
100 times so it's about 150 per wear
yeah
pretty good not that sounds like good
math to me it doesn't it sounds like a a
dumb decision that I made but I feel
like every time I wear it I'm remedying
the situation you know and I feel like
oftentimes you find yourself in a place
where it's like what do I wear there's
fabulous jacket but it's also like it's
a casual situation I can't wear we're
not wearing ball gowns like right I just
need like a casual cool look bendy
windbreaker no it's so not me you know
I'm like so cheap like I
like if it's not a 10 shirt like I don't
want it
however this jacket did speak to me and
I feel good you know it was an
investment I take good care of it I
could sell it on the real real like it's
good it's so good so if you guys ever
see like a triple XL windbreaker on the
real real just know it came from your
girl's closet okay and she just she find
the buyers are worse like finally kicked
in you should leave a note in the pocket
for a toast I'll sew it in so like you
just break open the seam and there's
like a little note being like hi yeah
enjoy sister heard of The Traveling
windbreaker
they should be so
fortunatebreaker it was a crazy ass
weekend
um like uh pop culture wise everyone was
talking about Cartier yes and honestly
like I'm
like I'm like literally not in the mood
like I can't explain how I'm not in the
mood I can't explain how I'm not in the
mood considering I've been thinking
about it like all weekend like the whole
this whole trajectory of his week it was
a wild busy week for Mr West it was a
busy week for him and
I'm not in the mood to talk about is
weak so
we're not we're not like I just I can't
like I appreciate everyone reaching out
it's lovely I we either like I I feel
like we can't do anything right like no
people are always like you only talk
about anti-Semitism and they're like so
butt hurt when we talk about
anti-Semitism almost to the point where
it feels anti-semitic
um but today when we say like we're not
gonna talk about anti-Semitism people
are gonna be even angrier yeah so you
know what like just eat my ass how about
that
I'm not in the mood I'm so tired of
everyone and their nonsense and just
leave me alone okay like seriously go
bother another influencer who's never
done anything in her life okay like
leave me alone no go bother another
influencer who's not been bothered yet
yeah yeah it's time to feel around us
alone like enough already I can't like
oh my anxiety has been on fleek these
past couple of weeks I just feel like
every time you know like every time I
check my phone it's like what now what
did I do now yeah but I'm just like a
lovely lovely girl I feel like that
won't you say is the biggest
misconception about you
oh my gosh there's so uh there's so many
but none that I really care to dispel
um because they're subjects I don't talk
about yeah I guess like my the biggest
misconception about me oh my God I
literally have seen like people
messaging me like I sell you 500 years
ago and you appeared to be being rude to
wait staff like one thing about me is
like Ah that's not me like I will
literally like lick someone's vagina
like I am so not like I will that's just
not me it's one of my biggest pet peeves
in other people so like when I see
people being like I saw Claudia in
college and she appeared to be giving
the waiter a dirty look I'm like please
shut the [ __ ] up like that's just not
true and then I often think about how
like you know we're so
beloved like we are like we we don't
even talk about like how like we're so
famous like it's insane and the amount
of like with all that love comes equal
amounts of hate and that's part of the
job for sure but like the way that like
I think we keep people up at night like
they think we're like so evil like and
how everything we do here is like just a
facade for sure but they feel even more
so that way about me oh yeah I know big
God oh my God I'm like they [ __ ] hate
you and you know what like there's still
hope for me and I'm thrilled I don't
know if honestly I didn't know if you
knew that like no no no I know I know so
um but like it's just the way they think
like everything we do and then they're
gonna clip this laugh and be like she's
as evil as we thought right but like
when you when it comes down to it like I
often think about how we're just like
literally so normal and so nice and like
we are you know normal people we are
kind we are generous we come here and we
talk about the Kardashians and you know
who maybe could win the Super Bowl and
suddenly we're like alt-right activists
like it's so crazy to me how like we are
just like two normal girls should
yeah
two normal girls two normal girls just
like going about their lives talking
about what they see totally
so what I see
is my own reflection and I can't really
you like what you see I can't really put
into words like how
fabulous that is you know
and you know I often think about how
part of the human experience is never
being able to see yourself the way other
people see you physically yeah and I'm
like literally so jealous of you that
like you can see what I look like like
I'm beyond curious
I'm beyond curious like not what I look
like because I I believe that the mirror
is an accurate reflection but just like
my man like what is it mannerisms no
like mannerisms you're gay like just
everything about your presence you know
that America couldn't capture because
you see yourself and then you change
what you're doing but a mirror is also
two-dimensional so like there's really a
limit to how much you can really see
yourself in a reflection even if is it
if it is an accurate reflection like I
would like to see a 360. like I don't
know what I look like I and I don't know
if that's just part of the human
experience or body dysmorphia I'm sure
that eventually just like you go to the
airport and you do that thing like they
could take like a bus to view 360 and
you could like see yourself in action
yeah but then you would see yourself
like Frozen in one moment and honestly
I'm not interested no no I think they
could have you like walking hmm
I don't know if it would be an accurate
reflection of your gate
yeah like when you look at me what do
you see
fabulosity dripping oozing gorgeousness
good answer I take back my middle finger
from before thank you that's called
healing and that's when you look at me
what do you see
hey
look at me that's what I say honestly
that's no when I look at you I see let
me think of the perfect word
when I look at you I see Perfection
honestly
perfectly sweet Claudia that's beautiful
there's no such thing but thank you no
such thing except for this show because
it's [ __ ] perfect yeah like we've
literally never said anything that isn't
totally perfect
100 it's perfect in its imperfections
that today is no exception because we've
got a fabulous show we have such
interesting stories interesting stories
today a lot of book news Memoir news
which is kind of one of my favorite
sorts of news just because it led us to
reading open book by Jessica Simpson
which is a story but speaking of book
news I read I'm in the middle of a book
right now and I finished a book this
weekend that I would like to share with
the class if everyone is interested sure
so I started on Friday on my way to
Atlanta but called the club by Ellery
Lloyd and it was like a little bit
murder mystery Soho House you know
exclusive Club actors actresses artists
and it was really really good it was
very descriptive which I don't think
will be like your favorite part
describing you know the furniture in the
new club and the windows whatever but
the storyline was really good and I
really enjoyed it I gave it four stars
and I would recommend it for anyone
who's looking for a little fabulous
Thriller which everyone's always asking
for a fabulous Thriller 100
and then I just started this book
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow and
it is like the book of the moment right
now it is yes not in your genre it's
about if I told you what it's about like
you wouldn't want to read it but it's
about like two kids they're now adult to
go to Harvard and MIT and they're really
into video games and they're gonna like
build their own video game I know it
doesn't sound good so oh so it's about
two nerds no yes some self-professed
nerds uh all the redheads were reading
it told Dana to read it Dana read it
told all of us to read it it's like
having a moment in the literary world
not in the Spice World well in the spice
world I read forever and ever which is a
Lucy score book and Lucy score is good
because I literally read a 700 page book
like can you believe whoa taking over
700 pages when you embarked no because I
was reading and I'm like this [ __ ] has
to be over soon right and I look them 67
I'm like what
so then I looked up how many pages it
was but I didn't mind it was a stunning
tale you know we had romance we had fear
we had murder it really had it all Lucy
score never fails and it was set in a
really cute random like place that she
found Mackinac Island which is like an
island off the coast of Michigan and
it's like totally like there's no cars
it's it was really cute
um and it was adorable I loved it brick
is you know like my boyfriend now and it
was fabulous fabulous fabulous brick
that's a good name well his name was
William but the girl who hands up with
they met when they were like teenagers
and she started calling him brick
because he was so big like a brick wall
that's a good name you know I was
watching Lauren Lane's story and she was
talking to she's having a baby boy
imminently and she was saying how she
used her favorite boy names for dutton's
first and middle name and she would
recommend others not do that because I
think they're struggling now and his
middle name is Walker so I guess she
would have named her second boy Walker
but she should name him brick
totally someone sent this to Lauren Lane
um so after the Fast Five we also have a
little TV recap the real house has a
Potomac Premiere this week nothing
really happened but what's good to catch
up with the ladies and even though we
did like an in-depth recap of House of
the Dragon on our patreon yesterday we
will talk about it here because our
house of the Dragon Recaps are on a
short list to win an Oscar 100 and we
can always talk about House of the
dragon and it was the best episode of
the series So Far So Truly stunning true
English stunning we need to recap again
so I think without further uh
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know
I think that's good
okay so like that was fine it was fine
it's not gonna like you know within the
crunch like has no context like the
crunch is an inside joke
yeah okay I know you know
right if you know you and also you send
me that Tick Tock of that girl yes I'm
telling you uh there was like this
creative agency I think it's called like
sauce Media or something they all the
girls who work at the agency are
toasters and they put together like this
little deck for us via Tick Tock with
all these different ideas they had for
our Rebrand and like I literally wanted
to use all of them yeah some of them are
really good and the girl was saying and
she was really funny
um and she really pitched I watched the
whole thing I thought it was so great
good ideas she was saying instead of the
Crunch and we couldn't get rid of the
crunch like things change it should be
like a sip sound like
yeah I mean I could record it myself
like because you know I'm really into
ASMR these days it would be like this
you know what else we could do other
shows have this we don't have any like
buffers with music you know like um
transitional stuff so maybe the Fastback
stories you need to know and then it's
like it goes into a theme song or
something well another part of the
Rebrand we haven't really discussed is
how does what kind of you know effect
does this have on Welcome to the morning
toast
welcome to the toast podcast
yeah I actually used our little jingle
at my show in Pittsburgh I opened the
show and I don't know what came over me
I was like welcome to the analog tour
welcome and everyone Jackie the place it
was like Ibiza people were lit the [ __ ]
up that's good it was really it was a
special moment if you were there you
know Pittsburgh toasters now p t k
are you ready to get into those fast
five stories that I previously mentioned
yes then you're ready and there's
nothing I'm ready I'm ready for the
aforementioned oh [ __ ] yeah so she's not
ready no I am
I am ready and if you're watching on
YouTube You'll see the Rebrand has
stepped up I got new curds for my ads
that say our new logo we have new flags
on our microphone with our new logo it's
just a very exciting day here at the
morning toast oh constantly elevating
the toast and the toast
is sponsored by seeds
turns out everything you think you know
about probiotics may be wrong just like
this probiotic tortilla trip sounded way
too good to be true and the good news is
that seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is the
real deal because favorite ad copy no
it's true like not me at Trader Joe's
like getting a tortilla chip probiotic
thinking it's going to solve all my
digestive problems spoiler where it
won't but thanks to seeds
it will because not all probiotics are
created equal so the daily symbiotic
from seeds what is it it is a broad
spectrum two in one probiotic and
Prebiotic it is a 24 strain broad
spectrum probiotic that's formulated for
Digestive gut immune and additional
systemic benefits the capsulin capsule
protects against stomach acid digestive
enzymes and bile salts for viability
through digestion so basically the live
probiotics will actually make it to the
end of the small intestine for delivery
into your colon if you've taken a
probiotic before and never felt a
difference it's likely because the good
bacteria wasn't surviving your GI tract
well seed is designed differently and
that's why it works it supports benefits
in and Beyond the gut so of course
you've heard forever like that taking a
probiotic or a Prebiotic is really good
for your gut digestion but seed is going
to support the ease of bloating Health
regularity ease of evacuation basically
you're going to be taking nice big
smooth dumps it'll also help support
your gut barrier your skin Health your
heart health and your micronutrient
synthesis so there's just like a list of
benefits beyond your gut
from taking a probiotic and seeds is a
brand that you can trust they're super
well developed your gut immune
function is about supporting the talk
between your intestinal cells and your
immune cells and seeds is going to do
just that a lot of people see
Improvement indigestion in just 24 to 48
hours which can include bowel movement
regularity and ease of bloating if you
struggle with bloating you know it's
kind of like this and never The Never
Ending uphill battle and try the seeds
daily symbiotic it's kind of stunning
I've been on it for quite some time
because I get really bad face bloating
obviously when I'm menstruating but also
just like when I'm alive each component
of their refill system is designed to
protect your ds01 daily symbiotic and be
gentler on Earth so if you are ready to
take the dive into a probiotic start a
new healthy habit today and visit
seed.com toast you can use code toast to
redeem 20 off your first month at seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic that's seed
s-e-e-d.com slash toast and use code
toast for 20 off your first month of
their daily symbiotic
period
end of story period
period we're a story some exciting
casting news for a book that's turning
into our movie our movie Yes Jessica
Simpson's Memoir open book has been
adapted as Amazon freebie pilot starring
Caitlin Tarver and John Stamos
Amazon freebie has ordered the half hour
scripted pilot open book based on the
Memoir by reality TV and pop star
Jessica Simpson the best member really
they're calling her reality TV and pop
star no they're disrespectful and they
obviously didn't read the book which is
now a reminder for everyone if you have
not read this book it is the best
celebrity Memoir aside from Claudia's in
the last seven years it's the best
celebrity memoir period like let's be
real my book is really good but it's not
even close to how good Jessica Simpson
says sorry okay well she's not me like
I'm a narcissist but like I'm not a liar
she said it I think a lot of narcissists
are liars I actually don't think you're
a narcissist no I'm just like extremely
self-involved and self-promotional and
I'll never let a chance slip by to
promote something that I you know worked
on yeah no she believes in herself I
believe in my products I don't think
that's a narcissist and that's why you
should go to seed.com toast and girl
with no job.com and girl with no job.com
tour I'm headed to Nashville show
Thursday finally you know after many
many months my Nashville show is here
I'm like literally so excited I just I'm
into Nashville in a year I don't know
I'm just since the girls trip right
which was when over a year ago a 2021
right I'm thrilled I'm excited for you
back to the story there's not a ticket
available so you won't be catching me
trying to promote anything
oh even though it sounded like you just
did but okay
um the project Stars Caitlin Tarver from
Ballers as Sadie Sparrow a young singer
based on Jessica Simpson while Stamos
from Full House is on board as Butch an
older musician who's tasked with writing
songs with Sadie but soon their
connection is much more than that
interesting so they're deviating from
the book she's not playing a young
Jessica I was like I don't remember
Butch from the book no and I don't think
there's a character in her book that's
Butch it's probably like an amalgamation
of her dad and some of the older like
Nick Lachey and John Mayer people that
she worked with but also had like a
relationship with relationship yeah yeah
all right I mean I guess it's better
because when I thought they were making
a series about like her life I thought
that was kind of weird and like very
lifetime Vibe yeah and also it's like
you're gonna have someone who's playing
Tony Romo when he's like just down the
street like it's weird no the way I
still to this day ship Tony Romo and
Jessica Simpson is not normal not normal
and if you need to know why just Google
Jessica Romo Jessica
what's her name Simpson Tony Romo
birthday cake blue icing like those
pictures when I was I remember like
seeing them in an Okay magazine when I
was 14 and I was not okay that I will do
right now because I'm not sure
do you know what pictures I'm talking
about no she threw him like this
birthday party that was like so
All-American football and she brought
out this big cake and they were just
like shoving the cake in each other's
mouth and then they get icing so cute
it's such a niche pop culture reference
but one that really molded me into the
the podcast host I am today I see it
it's gorgeous for me the story about the
two of them that warms my heart was um
when they were dating this is in her
book when they were dating I think she
bought him a boat and he would take all
of his friends out on the boat and play
her music and sing along to it and be
like isn't my girl so talented no I'm
telling you like there was it was right
person wrong time is that the picture
I can't really say it's like a selfie no
no oh are they eating icing yeah oh I
see I see
it was like oh and they're kissing with
the icing remember when celebrities used
to throw themselves like big 21st 22nd
birthday parties or like sponsors and
the paparazzi that was like an iconic
moment in pop culture history like
everyone's birthday party was like this
big Tada with like a red carpet
yes and she threw him one of those and
it was literally I think like Sky Vodka
was like the sponsor it was so cute
so cute take me back I buried that book
again I know they're right person wrong
time like I really feel like they were a
good match even though I know Tony Romo
has like a I know I don't know what his
wife's name is but I know she's like
people love her she's like a Dallas
influencer like I'm not knocking them at
all so happily married they have a
beautiful life and Jessica's so happily
married and has a beautiful life so and
I'm obsessed with both but everything is
as it should be I do often think about
like an alternate universe where the two
of them had ended up together you know
and like he retired she took a step back
from the spotlight like they would have
been on like similar paths but he's uh
still doing broadcasting in sports and
she's like Mogul moves and if Jessica
ended up with Tony then Jessica's
daughter would not be playing basketball
with North
we wouldn't have that no because he she
would probably be living in Dallas
I just feel like and then also they
would have had their kids earlier asiao
of North's basketball team you don't
know that North's basketball team is
like kind of bigger than the NBA no I
feel like everyone's always talking
about North basketball it's even like
they're in the playoffs and like what
happened at this game by the way I bet
that just based on where they live it's
a lot of like famous athletes kids on
that team yeah and I bet like I could
see North going to the WNBA I think
North's basketball team is bigger than
the WNBA I think that North is probably
the only person out there who can make
the WNBA like cool and relevant agreed
because the WNBA has a branding problem
they really do mm-hmm
they really do and I think we just
solved it
North just another day another sleigh
that's us
that says anyways open book will be
turned into a show Jessica posted on her
Instagram today that she's been so
excited to announce this they've been
working on it for years and how this
book like changed her life and like I
think the perception of her in the
industry to the public which I think it
did for everyone who read it change my
perception of her and that's what a good
book can do so my perception of her like
didn't need to be changed it just was
enhanced
enhanced because I I don't know if I've
mentioned this but me and Jessica
Simpson have the same birthday so we've
always felt this like inextricable
connection yeah I feel that I would love
to do the birthday buddies project now
but we've done this recently where we
looked up who has the same birthday as I
was like for me jade yeah but when you
were a child
yeah when I was a child it was Sally
Field who was it now now I think it's um
well Lamar Odom and Paige de Sorbo and I
not only have the same birthday but we
were born on the same day of the same
because you're the same age we're the
same that's pretty crazy someone pointed
that out to me once and I think that's
so crazy yeah no I don't think me and
Jessica have that or Erica that's too
bad no you think I also have the same
birthday as Sofia Vergara I think I have
like a really good birthday I think you
do too but also because Claudia ashrae
was born right and I feel like being
rewarded with good birthday buddies is
what I get for having to grow up with a
summer birthday if you know you know
yeah
so that's the power of what reading can
do someone tell Ben that this is why
literacy is so important in women for
women yeah I agree
are you ready for our next story people
are quaking because Blink 182 has
announced a reunion tour with the band
co-founder Tom Delong have you been
seeing this everywhere significance no
Ben doesn't Okay Ben oh Ben probably had
him woken up to the news yet no Ben also
like he's just now finding out about you
know World War II he's so delayed it's
beyond Blink 182 surprise fans by
announcing that they are united
reuniting for a massive World Tour and
will put out a new song this week Travis
Barker Mark hoppis and Tom Delong will
be coming together for the first time in
nearly 10 years to before perform new
music all across the world the punk
rockers also announced that they will be
dropping their new single edging this
Friday wait I totally forgot that Travis
Barker's in blink 182. yes and this Tom
Delong hasn't been with the band in so
long and now he's back with the band and
people are so excited but I thought that
Blink 182 was like on tour Courtney's
always yeah me too backstage but Travis
goes on tour with like Machine Gun Kelly
he does drums for a lot of people so I
don't know so I could see yeah like he
wasn't doing Blink 182 shows he was
doing like you know
independent work yeah the um Travis and
De Long like had a falling out they
reunited and now everyone's coming back
together I feel like for a lot of punk
rock fans this is like if the Spice
Girls went on tour no this is Fab I mean
Ben is not gonna be okay he's gonna want
to go and you should take him a hundred
percent
I feel like the tickets are kind of
going to be hard to get like I think so
they work your connections yeah totally
totally I'll just reach out to my people
people have your people call his people
that's exciting I mean I feel like it
was like a big weekend for emo kids
because it was also Lollapalooza and
Paramore
um performed and they allegedly like
unretired misery business so they
performed and I don't think they perform
it a lot and I was seeing videos like I
looked like I never wanted to go to
lollaplus in my life but actually it
looked so fun that does look fun I'm
sure you were upset when they weren't
performing it because they are shunning
the thing that made them famous yeah I
actually
um I've been thinking about that a lot
lately one of my biggest pet peeves as
everyone knows is like when people don't
acknowledge the thing that made them
famous and with singers like if you're
not going to sing your number one hit
like even Harry Styles sings That's What
Makes You Beautiful still like honor
your roots
um
and I was I somehow ended up on this
like twisted side of tick tock where
people were going to the Tyler Childers
concert in Red Rocks Red Rock Red you
know Tyler I don't know Tyler Childers
but I know Red Rocks so Tyler Childers
like I've I've learned so much from Tic
Tac he's like this prolific songwriter
he's country but he's also like more
alternative and he's not mainstream at
all like very
um I don't know if I would say country
it's like it's like Moody like Mumford
and Sons Vibes like you know okay oh
yeah and
um and so Tyler Childers I actually from
my lovely lady okay wait that's like not
how it goes sorry lady May
I don't know it but literally stretch on
um no I don't
um
Buckle makes Impressions on the inside
of her thigh you know that no I I don't
but this okay like he has like this cult
like following his these iconic songs
that like people are obsessed with and
uh he recently just released an album so
that's why everyone was talking about
him and he's uh at Red Rocks and people
were like literally not leaving the
stadium because he didn't play like
feathered Indians like his iconic songs
um and he didn't come back he's like no
[ __ ] I'm done and normally that's like
my biggest pet peeve however
it's because a lot of those songs are
about his addiction and he's now sober
and I think he thinks it would be like
too traumatizing I do feel like in a few
years maybe he'll go back to playing
them but right now I think his sobriety
is kind of new not the time I'll I'll
allow it then like if you have a good
reason but if you're just being a snob
like not wanting to play you know your
number one hits like even Miley she's
back to playing the Seven Things I Hate
About You
yeah it took her long enough took her
long enough because she did I'd Hannah
for for as long as she could you know
who's so good about that and another
reason why we stand as hard as we do
Kelly Clarkson
yes but Gavin DeGraw
I've been to his concert for every album
that he puts out and in every single
concert he talks about the song that
changed his life Chariot you know One
Tree Hill the big hits while still
promoting like his new stuff right I'm
so sorry no it's okay just move on I
didn't know um I
agree I love that Kelly Clarkson is
great about that too I was just watching
She's Kelly okaying actually today on
her show with Sam Smith they're doing
this like iconic harmonizing cover of
breakaway I saw like a little clip it
looks so good oh can't wait I love a
queen who respects their Origins like I
really do your history let me it all
comes back to history let me tell you
one thing that I'm that's not working
for you and me got a whole lot of
history
um let me tell you I love winter but
something about the new season has
started to have the sun shine directly
into my eye while we're podcasting if
you're watching on YouTube you can
probably see this glare of light it's
pissing me the [ __ ] off yeah I know your
eye is looking a little funky I think
you're keeping an eye out for Selena
gorgeous hat not to sound like Lisa
Rinna but my friend Kendall Jenner sent
you that hat for the party hat for the
party tonight so I hate the studio like
I'm done with it
or you can get a blind installed yeah
like that would be much easier than you
know breaking my lace
but that wouldn't
um solve the truckers and the ambulances
and the horns so true but they had
Charisma to the show they do and they
always make their opinions known 100 are
you ready for our next story a little
Galactic Intergalactic news is it a
little Galactic Intergalactic news
that's brought to you by stamps.com yes
it is if you're a small business owner
you know how important it is to be ready
for the insane holiday season if you
haven't
started preparing for the chaos of
holiday mailing and chipping you're
already falling behind not to give you
anxiety but luckily stamps.com has
everything you need to make your whole
life a lot easier it's a 24 7 post
office that you can access from anywhere
no lines no traffic and certainly no
hassle for more than 20 years stamps.com
has been an indispensable resource for
over a million businesses you'll get
access to USPS and UPS shipping Services
all the things you need to run your
business right from your computer with
inflation On The Rise and it's hella
Rising every dollar counts protect your
margins with major discounts from USPS
and UPS rates they get up to 86 percent
off
it is a stress-free solution for every
small business use stamps.com to print
postage wherever you do your business
all you need is a computer and a printer
and if you need a package pickup you can
easily schedule it through your
stamps.com dashboard rates are
constantly changing but with their
switch and save feature you can easily
compare carriers you can compare rates
so you know that you're getting the best
deal every time and if you're running an
online store stamps.com Works seamlessly
with all the major shopping carts and
marketplaces so get ahead of the holiday
chaos this year and get started with
stamps.com today sign up with promo code
toast for a special offer that includes
a four week trial plus free postage and
a free digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts
required just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code toast again you can get that
four week trial free postage and a
digital scale at stamps.com
t-o-a-s-t thanks to stamps.com for
sponsoring Today's Show withstamps.com
toast
great okay our next story William
Shatner describes his overwhelming
sadness he fell for Earth in his blue
origin flight to space so we talked
about how William Shatner went to space
aboard the blue origin spaceship last
fall it seemed like the perfect
opportunity to strike profound joy and
celebration into a man who had played a
space traveler for on TV for decades but
Shatner who was 90 at the time of his
flight in his a longtime environmental
Advocate writes in a new book that the
experience was among the strongest
feelings of grief that he had ever
encountered in excerpt from his book he
said I had thought that going into space
would be the ultimate catharsis of that
connection I had been looking for
between all living things that being up
there would be the next beautiful step
to understanding the harmony of the
universe
he said when he went there I had a
different experience because I
discovered that the beauty isn't out
there it's down here with all of us
leaving that behind made my connection
to our tiny planet even more profound it
was among the strongest feelings of
grief I have ever encountered the
contrast between the vicious coldness of
space and the warm nurturing of Earth
Below fill me with overwhelming sadness
so he had a bad time is what he said he
had a bad time he said space is
depressing like you think it's all fun
and games out there and it's a whole new
world but the real world and the great
world is the one that we're living in so
why don't we [ __ ] appreciate it no
it's so true I want to take care of that
instead of spending millions of dollars
taking [ __ ] to space
yeah to see this well actually maybe
it's a good lesson to have these people
go to space especially someone like
William Shatner who was he's an
Intergalactic King
and now he's going to get back down here
to tell us no this is where it is this
is where it's at and this is what we've
been saying like of course everything
comes back to us not to make literally
everything about us but we've kind of
been saying how like [ __ ] on Earth is
like lit and they need our help down
here and we should be focusing here
right and not worrying about what's
going on I mean
like astronaut should go to space space
exploration is so important I'm talking
about civilians the experts should keep
doing the work that they're doing but I
think for everyone else like I don't
think we should just
tear [ __ ] up down here and then be like
oh it's okay I'll go live on Mars right
like drop everything now meet me in
Saturn
meet me in Saturn yeah I love William
Shatner and I love getting wisdom from
like clearly someone who's lived long
you know intellectually I think this is
very interesting and wise and not that I
ever had the space itch but I certainly
don't now no it's true like
you're like literally so far from home
like yeah it's like kind of psychotic it
is also you saw that Pete Davidson is no
longer going to space did we talk about
this on the show we did we did or I
think it might have been a day that you
weren't here because I remember talking
about it with like Shannon or something
oh okay I just remembered him going to
space again because of the Kardashians
episode oh which did you watch no oh I
forgot what happened oh it was good and
bad okay there was just like some [ __ ]
I'll catch up this week and we'll recap
in full okay cool uh she Kim was talking
about how he is going to space in the
episode so it's top of mind and was she
worried about it
she was just saying how she could never
right because like she has maybe she
said maybe if I didn't have four kids I
would of course but she could never no
and that it's not something that
interests her and I very much related
yeah like if they seriously I think
we've spoken about this if they wanted
everyone wants like the first you know
oldest person youngest person I think
they have a cancer survivor like
everyone wants to be the first to
everyone if they wanted the first
podcaster to go to space like would we
say yes
um how much money are we talking it also
depends like whose Fleet honestly I
don't have like that much faith in
Richard Branson it's like I'm going to
Elon or Bezos like um because you know
what I'm American I'm going Elon even
though elon's not American oh right but
he lives in America yeah no I think I'm
going low-key so true I totally forgot
he's not American yeah I think I'm going
Elon though honestly Jeff Bezos is
getting people there and back quite
safely no I feel safe with Bezos I mean
my packages arrive safely why wouldn't I
that's true I would feel comfortable
going on Blue origin but I don't know
what the Virgin one is called it's
probably called virgin
um I don't know I don't have a good
feeling about it okay good thing
nobody's asking us right and that's the
thing about these kind of hard decisions
that our hypothetical scenarios in my
head is that they're never going to come
to fruition right and you could just
Let It Go like if they seriously wanted
the first podcaster like it would be Joe
Rogan right yeah and Elon would take him
up in a minute and be over and done with
I'm sure it's already happened right I
don't think he would go Blue origin
because Amazon podcast is a direct
competitor to Spotify yeah and elon's
like his best friend oh right he went on
his podcast oh by the way I could see a
world in which Joe Rogan goes and like
records something yeah
is like one of the most unflattering
things I've ever put on I think you look
so cool
maybe like from the way you're looking
at me but in the camera like I look like
a grandma going to play Pickleball
there are worse things are there
no yeah you could be playing tennis
true
are you ready for our next story
I really honestly and truly am okay it's
a little more book Memoir news because
we haven't even talked about how Kelly
Ripa has dropped a memoir
um Kelly's mindless Memoir but
Kathy Lee Gifford is defending Regis
Philbin from Kelly Ripa's Memoir claims
yes Kathy Lee klg the thing is I love
Kathy Lee
in her upcoming book titled Livewire
Ripa said it was a basic misconception
that she and Regis were close friends
outside of work it's also so confusing
to have a story about William Shatner
and then Regis Philbin because to me
they're the same person I I hear that I
don't have the same experience but I
respect yours especially because in Miss
Congeniality William Shatner played that
host who was supposed to be Regis
Philbin that's why it's Regis yeah it's
just a lot it's giving Regis
Ripa said in one passage of her book
quote my name had to be smaller than
regis's name on the live title card and
branding obviously a game of inches
which speaks for itself but on that we
agreed seniority after all she also
claimed from the very very beginning
that Regis didn't like her and even
dubbed her as quote it in contrast Kathy
Lee Gifford said she shared a special
relationship with her former co-host
calling him the best partner she could
have had she said I know what Regis was
to me he was 15 years the best partner I
could have had professionally he was my
friend we were dear friends and after I
left the show for the next 20 years we
became better friends dearer friends
right she said she replaced Kathie Lee
Gifford right yes and Kathy Lee Gifford
said she never knew Regis to be anything
but so kind to everyone yeah I mean I
feel like it's very easy to write your
Memoir um when like about a person
like he's he's gone like he's not gonna
defend himself so I think it's nice that
Kathy Lee Gifford
is there sharing her experience and like
one thing about me is I was really
deeply
um affected
by Kelly Ripa Michael Strahan Saga of
like 2018 like it made me change how I
look at Kelly Ripa so deeply like I am
like I am extremely doubtful of her
intentions I really am
yeah I wonder if there's a short story
in her book about that well there should
be and it should be a big ass apology to
Michael Strahan but yeah she acted like
a toddler right I'm sorry uh
her being all mad that like Regis his
name is
right right and like that's that's
really like that's like the
entertainment industry it's like there
are stars that are bigger than others
and the bigger stars get better
treatment and when it's been someone's
show for 15 years like they are the
headliner and then she comes on and she
establishes herself and eventually it's
her show and and but like that's what
you do you work your way up every time I
hear Kelly Ripa talk about like the
Genesis and just the overall Arc of her
career it's giving ungrateful like
always
she got the show from Regis
she had a host of different uh
co-hosts
she had a breakdown with Michael Strahan
like every time we're like talking about
the Arc of La the live with whoever show
it's always like Kelly Ripa like rubbing
me the wrong way yeah and this is like
the one part of Kelly's life that is not
mindless
no no so hopefully that's what's in the
book yeah in the book put in the book
it's a book of short stories which is
always a great digestible way to consume
as a celebrity Memoir no and it's
literally everywhere like every
celebrity's talking about it People
magazine is like literally not going to
be okay with how much content they're
turning out it's really it's a lot yeah
it is a lot but you know that like they
were doing the most when there was
nothing to talk about like now there's a
whole ass book right now something
happened right
yeah I'm hearing about it I feel like I
haven't heard enough bad things about
Regis to like totally write him off like
I feel like Regis was a p-job and I I
want to continue to believe that I feel
like Regis was a peach I'm too and what
I know about Kelly is like she's kind of
a diva so
that diva is like we're flipping it on a
Ted mclared yeah she's a traditional
meaning not the alternative New Media
meaning
in the way that Mariah Carey means it
yeah or even we were just saying last
week about you being a diva right yeah I
don't mean it in that way I mean it in
like the old school way of like throwing
water at your assistant you know Naomi
Campbell Naomi Campbell are you ready
for a fifth and final story someone who
is not a pee drum
Bill Murray some anti-pjam news and taip
jam news have you heard of there's not a
PJ no there is Major drama with Bill
Murray he's been accused of paying a
female movie star for a hundred thousand
dollars after he quote kissed her body
pinned her down and straddled her
leaving the woman unable to move on set
of a new movie that he was working on
that was supposed to be on Aziz ansara's
Aziz ansari's new movie they got through
50 of filming this incident happened
Bill Murray paid this woman a hundred
thousand dollars to sign an NDA and not
talk about it and now like the movie's
on hold
um
so here's the story The Woman claimed
she was unable to move because of his
weight it is alleged with Murray later
paying the woman a hundred thousand
dollars the April incident on set of the
20 million dollar movie controversial
comedian anziz ansari's direct
directorial debut is he controversial
because of that one thing that story
yeah I've you know it's so funny like I
was just thinking about this the other
day I don't think I will ever get over
the time literally two weeks ago where
we were we were reading an article about
Ansel Elgort and not once did they
mention the fact that like a year ago he
was accused of Brave and we were just
talking about how like people just
decide who to move on from and I feel
like Aziz I'm sorry like never really
got like a full reset and I think of all
the the people who might deserve one
like Aziz Ansari might be one of them I
think um I think I I honest to God think
like that whole situation was like
really unfortunate but not malicious I
agree and I think most people agreed and
there was a big op-ed in the New York
Times in defense of Aziz Ansari like I
think he he came close to like to you
know being a me too but I don't know if
that's really who he is
um so the fact that they still call him
controversial comedian and then
literally like Ansel Elgort gets to run
around and like not even be mentioned
that like he was accused of rape like
people are so [ __ ] I don't know like
how anyone can trust the media honestly
like this is so insane like I have not
stopped thinking about that Ansel Elgort
thing for months yeah anyways this
incident caused Disney to shut down
production and there's no indication as
to whether the movie will ever be
completed Murray had been overly
friendly and allegedly sexual with one
free male production staffer whose name
has been kept Anonymous the actor claims
that he believed the woman had been
flirting with him and at one stage he
and the woman were close to a bed it was
then that he allegedly began kissing her
and straddling her leaving her unable to
move because he was on top of her he
then moved in to kiss the woman on the
mouth the pair were both wearing face
masks it is claimed the alleged action
took place in front of witnesses
also this week
um
uh hold on give me one second Gina
Davis's Memoir came out and she also was
talking about an experience she had with
Bill Murray where he like berated her
when she was a young actress so Bill
Murray is
well that's so unfortunate
um and it's just I feel like we were
just having this conversation like
honestly in a lot of ways when I can't
come to like times up in Hollywood like
it was a farce like not really nothing
changed and we were all just talking
about it now but there's no actual like
systemic changes and like so many people
who are still in every room are bad
people and they are we're just like
holding their breath the whole time
just hoping the spotlight wouldn't land
on them and now that it's over
they've gotten away with it and I really
don't think anything is going to change
right and I just personally don't
believe that men like Aziz Ansari are
the problem like I really don't like
Aziz Ansari just sounds honestly like a
freak and if I went on a date with him
I'd be like you're weird like go away
but I don't think he's like a predator I
really don't
um so it's like you read articles
controversial comedian and then it's
like this is not like the actual problem
like this is not the problem yeah no
there's like real
tier one problems in Predators still out
there yes so it's just like I'm really
sick of Hollywood in their [ __ ] honestly
like preaching shut the [ __ ] up okay
shut up yeah speaking of Harvey
weinste's trial is starting this week in
L.A but I also feel him I know but I
feel like people feel like okay we got
Harvey like it's done solve problem
solved and there's so many Harveys there
are so many people who enable people
like Harvey and they're still working
yeah busy busy busy I thought Harvey was
like in jail like period yes he is
the perhaps awaiting trial perhaps into
the Sun or it's another trial because
there already was one trial right in New
York this one's in L.A oh yeah yeah yeah
got it got it
um well wishing him the worst always and
forever XOXO Gossip Girl Let's dive into
the TV recap we're gonna talk about
House of dragon and a little bit of
Potomac there's not much to say and I
know you didn't watch it but like it
doesn't matter okay again I didn't watch
but I want to hear what you think and
we'll resume official Recaps next week
yes the TV recap is brought to you by
ZipRecruiter did you know that there are
over 2.4 million podcasts in the world
including the one you're listening to
right now and you might not know that
the one that you're listening to right
now is the best out of those 2.4 million
just a fun fact brought to you by
ZipRecruiter and it takes a team of
people to bring together a podcast and
whatever it is that you do whatever your
passion is it takes a lot of people to
make your passion come to life so
needless to say hiring the right people
for these roles is super important
whether you're hiring for a podcast or
you're growing business there's only one
place that makes it easy and that's zip
recruiter right now you can try it for
free at zip dot com slash toast
ZipRecruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply additionally ZipRecruiter has a
complete Suite of tools that makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates four out of five employers
who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day so if
you're a fan of this podcast and you
want to try ZipRecruiter for free today
you just need to remember this link it's
ziprecruiter.com toast once again that's
Zip Zip
recruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire
thank you mclared okay The Real
Housewives of Potomac like you just need
to know the only one who's made any sort
of like change in their life is Ashley
Darby like giselle's still talking about
her house Wendy's still talking about
like being a professor and having her
titties out and now she's opening a
restaurant like it's the same thing I
just I do it all like it's boring what
happened to the candles
still doing the candles and now she's
opening a restaurant with Cynthia from
real houses of Atlanta's ex-husband
Peter mm-hmm it was crazy to see him
there he's like kind of hot Peter does
he live there now I don't know but he
was just like a smooth talk-in like I
was really like I was feeling his Vibe
I'm like yes I I'll give you the 300
Grand like he was really like making an
impact it's a Nigerian Lounge
then Robin I'm getting married I'm not
getting married wait I think I am
getting married oh no I'm getting
married so boring Ashley Darby is
actually making a change she is getting
divorced uh Candace Dillard Bessette uh
I want to have kids the schedule the
schedule the kids the eggs the schedule
the kids like it's the same [ __ ] from
everyone and the only thing anyone could
talk about is Ashley Darby because she's
the only one actually making progress in
her life oh my God that's imperating
what's up with Karen Huger it doesn't
bother me that she's up to the same old
[ __ ] like just being a queen talking
about Rey talking about Raven Raven's
moving to New York like I don't care
it's the same [ __ ] but it's Karen so so
it's enjoyable that's really crazy I
feel like
usually there's so much movement from
season to season and I feel like we
haven't seen Potomac in so long if I
don't even remember when it was last on
and that's disappointing Mia had some
health updates that all the women were
being rude about because she was like
being thirsty on social media talking
about if she has cancer and then she
edited the caption she doesn't have
cancer she had to go to Johns Hopkins
Cancer Center so it was like a little
bit confusing
um
but there is actually a lot of
interesting things going on in Mia's
life in real time did you see I saw that
her husband's brother like stole all
their money bankrupt to them like they
have their money yeah I saw that just
last week yeah
I don't know the details though but
that's not on the show maybe it'll be on
the reunion but it's not currently being
spoken about so the only thing that like
Karen threw a party and all the women
are bent out of shape that Ashley is
separated but her and Michael are buying
a home together in the name of their LLC
like their LLC will be on the deed and
it's because you know Michael lives in
this townhouse he wants to go out and
party Ashley doesn't drink anymore she's
now is two or three kids
two so she has her kids she doesn't
drink Michael's like very into like the
party life you know like when they were
having threesomes like he still wants to
do that and she's a mom now she's
growing up like they're just really on
two different planets but you know she
wants a house for her and her kids
that's good and currently
in order to get that she needs it to be
in her and Michael's name so all the
other women are like cracked out of
shape like
bent out of shape like I don't know and
it's like I understand like she's
playing the game she's doing what she
has to do to get the house that she
needs for her and her family and if
that's what she has to do it's what she
has to do yeah it's really
straightforward to me no but like
Giselle is like out of her mind of
course that's not a divorce like shut up
shut up
but she did kind of like read Wendy to
filth which was like a glorious moment
I'm like so I like don't like Wendy and
when they all came to Karen's party like
her and when they have not spoken since
the reunion and like Wendy took a big
dump on Giselle during the reunion and
so Wendy comes into the party he's
giving everyone's hugs being so fake
gives Giselle a hug and I was like do
not touch me like she said she literally
was like don't touch me like I don't
know goodbye and it was fabulous oh okay
I can't wait to watch and get into the
season and the real television news
everyone is talking about was Sunday
night's episode of House of the Dragon
which was Monumental
um spoiler alert
it was you know the official last
episode with the King he did pass away
but not before uh ruining everyone's
lives in the process by being you know
classic old scatterbrained old man
um Allison thinks that aegon not the
Conqueror but her moronic son should be
king when that's just not the case and
somebody lied to her several times and
told her that aegon was fly hot and sexy
and beautiful and he's nothing like that
he's nothing of the sort I don't even
know why she would want him to be king
like she sees him for what she is and
she's actually like you know she's not
even being like full Cersei about it
she's really like trying to discipline
him as best as she can like trying to
make right as best as she can all of his
errors like so true why would she will
be a horrible evil King and like she
knows that that's so true like she's
she's not blindly she's not blind to the
fact that like a Joffrey like Cersei was
like she knows her son is [ __ ] evil
and he literally just attacked that girl
and the next one kid is even worse yeah
um it was a beautiful episode though
like for I got like super emotional when
the king showed up for an era like and
it actually made me feel bad like that
she had like kind of left him over these
last couple of years because I'm
literally gonna cry talking about it
like he really was like he loved her so
much and you know everyone wanted him to
name aegon as the heir and he never From
This Moment he decided on
like he never wavered and she was like
kind of like a brat
um she was a brat remember like when we
had old Rainier and they had all those
like dinners and stuff and she was just
being like a stubborn teenager I know
and like it was never good enough but he
was so loyal to her and like he showed
up for her always like even at the end
when he couldn't even get out of bed and
half of his face was melted off like he
got up out of his bed he did not drink
the milk of the puppy and he showed the
[ __ ] up for his daughter and like I was
so I was like deeply moved by that like
really me too and put the whole thing to
bed because it would have sent the whole
realm and obviously rhaegera's
uh position and everything into disarray
if the high Towers had gotten away with
what they wanted to it would have caused
major problems because also would mean
that Jace couldn't inherit after
rhaenyra right and the King was like not
today no and I loved that even though I
did feel bad for the man stepping
forward because
um he was not lying like he was
literally speaking truths about
everything
um and he got his head shut up cut off
for literally speaking truth yeah but he
wasn't honoring his brother's wishes no
he wasn't and at the end of the day I
would have been like sad for the
um
valerians if Luke had taken the throne
and then really no more Valerian but
blood would be on the throne but now
that he'll be married his darling cousin
it will once again be Valerian and they
are the only Valerian children so they
would have been on the throne anyway
honestly it really works out nicely no
it was an inspired deal on renera's part
to have her kids marry Damon's kids and
it's really just Blended and it was a
great idea because like as much as I
wanted you know raniera's kids to get
what they deserve like it's a whole his
it's like the bloodline ending
with them and like that sucks yeah so
now it does so everyone wins everyone
wins they still have Targaryen love
Valerian blood and a little strong blood
and Damon's daughters get really nice
husbands because raniera's boys are good
kids yeah and that's not really common
common and
in Westeros you never know what you're
gonna get in a husband no even when they
were just like sitting at dinner like
they knew they were betrothed and it was
just like it was so cute and I think
like
you know of all the guys that they could
have ended up with in their position
they could end up with an aegon or an
aemond of course and they got a Jace
who's so they're pjoms they are
I'm very happy we're near a situation
aside from now that she has to go to
civil war with um Allison and the high
Towers she's really living like such a
great life with her man's abundant
family she's got two kids with her man's
one on the way they have like eight
right they're on their way to eight kids
and it's beautiful oh and four of them
are marrying each other it's absolutely
stunning just watching them like because
now like it's six years later so they're
not like in the honeymoon phase like
they're just married so like watching
them in their classic everyday married
life just like holding hands my love
like it's the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me in my entire life yeah
and Rainier on her own and her claim to
the throne like she's a little
I don't want to say like shaky but I
think we yeah
but with Damon Unstoppable and with all
these different kids we've got
targaryens we've got yeah what do you
want we got them we got Valerian we've
got them all we've got them all we've
got Harry hall right right if anyone's
looking if anyone's interested
I just love the show so much like it's
it's really very good me and Ben were
saying like I don't recall Game of
Thrones season one being this good like
it got really good the last episode and
then like but I don't recall being this
invested this quickly no I don't think
that we were I think it has to do with
the passage of time also Game of Thrones
season one there were literally seven
story lines so we would be going
somewhere that you don't really care
what's going on there yet yeah maybe in
some episodes not even see your faves it
was hard to feel connected to the
characters but they were setting a
larger scene there it was like the war
monkeys there was a million wars being
fought so we needed to get to know
everyone now there's just the one war
and so I think it's a little easier to
fall in love with your babes when at the
end of the episode The King dies and
he's like my love
was that his last words yeah I feel like
he saw his like his real wife well he
was always calling Allison Emma Emma you
know like Emma was OTP for sure but
Allison was a good wife and I feel like
people think she's so evil and she's she
was a good wife she's definitely got an
evil streak but she's not all bad I
think after this episode maybe she turns
and is gonna be like here he goes her
villain origin story yeah but up until
this point like yeah
she was just trying to do what's best
for her kids and she Andrea like really
was so obviously you know she slept with
her dad so that right
changes things wasn't her fault but for
years she was trying to bring rhaenyra
into the fold and Rainier wasn't
interested and it wasn't her fault and
also she was also just a product of men
just using women to get what they want
yeah and like now when when we came back
six years later she's like deeply
religious and she like loves
um
to take care of the king like I really
didn't hate her that much this episode
but I do think my hatred will have a
Resurgence next week yes but the
religious stuff and all like the seven
symbolism it was harking back to Cersei
when she brought in all those fanatics
and oh yeah but also because like in
King's Landing like they don't believe
in that [ __ ] no they believe in the old
guy it's not a Targaryen Ting no it's
not so I think it wasn't meant to be a
positive thing that she's become a woman
of God I know oh that's true and it was
her way of like bringing her [ __ ] into
yeah and we know this we know you know
what the seven are capable of from oh I
didn't realize that was the Cersei girly
it's Shame Shame girlies yeah
that was a crazy [ __ ] episode
the shame one yeah yeah like that'll go
down in history as one of the most crazy
episodes
do you see Cersei got married this
weekend
who do you think from House of the
Dragon is going to be nominated for in
Emmy
or a Golden Globe
people were saying viserys the king yeah
so I think it'll be I think it will
probably be Ensemble I think it will be
Rainier Damon viserys
because rhaenyra's only been in two
episodes and the total she's only gonna
have been in like four so Damon and
viserys I think Damon will even though
Damon literally said one word this
entire episode actually Four he can keep
his tongue five
um and it was the best moment of my life
literally literally like chop my head
off to it
do it Damon do it
no he's and that just that's that on
that is what he said like call my wife a
[ __ ] one more [ __ ] time no and it's
like okay so maybe if Rainier's Sons got
to keep the throne this guy would always
be chirping running his mouth good to go
that's that on that period out of story
it was a gorgeous episode it was a
gorgeous day here with you I love you
dearly love you dearly we've got another
Fab episode for you guys tomorrow so
we'll see you then thank you so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories they need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that's Spotify iTunes to cheer
public radio I Heart Radio I gotta make
a little jingle out of that love you
guys have an amazing day and we'll see
you tomorrow bye bye